selamat datang kembali ke Memahami Maklumat dan Pengkomputeran Kuantum nama saya John Watrous dan saya ialah
pengarah teknikal pendidikan di IBM Quantum ini ialah pelajaran ke-eth dalam siri ini dan ia merupakan pelajaran terakhir dalam
unit kedua siri ini yang berkaitan dengan algoritma kuantum kita dah bincangkan model pertanyaan pengkomputeran termasuk
algoritma kuantum yang menawarkan kelebihan terbukti berbanding algoritma klasik dalam model tersebut kita dah bincangkan Konsep asas yang berkaitan dengan
algoritma kuantum dan cara kita boleh mengukur kos pengkomputeran dan dalam pelajaran sebelumnya kita dah bincangkan anggaran fasa dan algoritma
Shor dalam pelajaran ini kita akan bincangkan algoritma Grover yang memberikan kelebihan kuadratik kuantum berbanding
algoritma klasik untuk masalah carian yang dipanggil carian tak berstruktur yang akan saya terangkan setelah kita masuk ke dalam
pelajaran ini semua ini merupakan topik asas berkaitan algoritma kuantum ada juga algoritma kuantum
yang lain serta paradigma umum yang menyatukan pelbagai algoritma kuantum dan teknik algoritma kuantum dan
kalau korang berminat saya galakkan korang tengok Quantum Algorithm Zoo yang mengkategorikan algoritma kuantum yang diketahui dan merangkumi banyak rujukan
kepada kertas penyelidikan asal yang telah menyumbang kepada pembangunannya untuk siri ini bagaimanapun
kita cuma akan berpegang pada asas-asas dan bermula dengan pelajaran seterusnya kita akan beralih ke topik baru tapi
pertama jom kita bincangkan algoritma Grover berikut ialah gambaran keseluruhan pelajaran kita akan mulakan dengan perbincangan singkat tentang
masalah pengkomputeran yang akan kita tangani iaitu carian tak berstruktur secara intuitif korang boleh
fikir tentang masalah carian tak berstruktur sebagai mencari melalui koleksi item yang tidak disusun dan tidak diatur dengan cara yang berguna
kemudian kita akan bincangkan algoritma Grover yang merupakan algoritma kuantum yang menawarkan kelebihan kuadratik berbanding
algoritma klasik dan kita akan mendalami apa yang dimaksudkan tak lama lagi penerangan sangat ringkas tentang
cara algoritma ini berfungsi ialah pertama ada langkah permulaan dan kemudian operasi yang akan saya rujuk sebagai
operasi grover diulang beberapa kali dan akhirnya pengukuran berlaku yang mendedahkan calon
penyelesaian kepada masalah carian saya akan terangkan apa itu operasi grover dan cara ia boleh
dilaksanakan pada komputer kuantum dan kemudian kita akan melalui analisis operasi ini untuk lebih memahami apa yang dilakukannya dan mengapa ia berguna untuk
mencari bahagian ketiga pelajaran ini berkaitan dengan bilangan iterasi
dalam algoritma Grover atau dengan kata lain berapa kali operasi grover harus digunakan dengan andaian bahawa kita ingin
memaksimumkan kemungkinan algoritma berjaya menemui apa yang kita cari sambil meminimumkan
kosnya kita akan mulakan dengan masalah carian unik yang merupakan kes khas di mana ada tepat satu penyelesaian untuk
masalah carian kita dan kemudian kita akan pertimbangkan apa yang berlaku apabila ada berbilang penyelesaian dan akhirnya saya akan simpulkan
pelajaran dengan beberapa catatan ringkas tentang algoritma Grover dan generalisasinya jom kita mulakan dengan
masalah pengkomputeran yang akan kita tangani sepanjang pelajaran pertama seperti yang selalu kita lakukan kita akan
biarkan Sigma menandakan abjad binari dan kita akan guna notasi ini untuk keseluruhan pelajaran jadi saya tak akan terus
mengingatkan korang andaikan kita mempunyai fungsi f yang memetakan rentetan binari dengan panjang n kepada
abjad binari andaian kita ialah kita boleh menilai fungsi ini dengan mudah contohnya
mungkin kita mempunyai circuit Boolean untuk fungsi ini yang saiznya adalah polinomial dalam N sekarang ini tidak bermakna bahawa ini adalah
fungsi yang mudah dalam apa jua erti kata atau kita mempunyai pemahaman yang sangat baik tentang fungsi ini contohnya mungkin kita mempunyai
circuit Boolean yang agak rumit dan bercelaru untuk mengira F yang membolehkan kita menilainya pada rentetan input yang berbeza tetapi tidak semestinya mempunyai
bentuk yang bagus yang direka untuk memudahkan kerja kita matlamat kita adalah untuk mencari penyelesaian dengan
maksud kita rentetan binari dengan panjang n yang menyebabkan F menilai kepada satu secara umum ini adalah masalah pengkomputeran yang sangat sukar
atau sekurang-kurangnya kita syak ia sangat sukar khususnya jika input sebenarnya ialah
penerangan circuit Boolean untuk mengira fungsi f maka ini adalah masalah yang dipanggil masalah NP lengkap satu cara
kita boleh memformalkan masalah ini ialah sebagai masalah pertanyaan dan memang untuk tujuan pelajaran ini adalah munasabah
untuk memikirkan masalah ini semata-mata dalam konteks model pertanyaan tetapi apabila kita fikir tentang di mana atau bila
masalah ini mungkin timbul dalam praktis ia lebih semula jadi untuk memikirkan f sebagai dikira oleh circuit Boolean
seperti yang kita lihat dalam pelajaran enam meskipun kita boleh menghubungkan dua sudut pandang ini melalui konstruksi yang kita lalui untuk mengambil circuit Boolean dan
menukarnya kepada circuit kuantum untuk melaksanakan operasi pertanyaan atau gate pertanyaan dalam apa jua keadaan secara konseptual
input kepada masalah ini ialah fungsi f ini dan kita sedang mencari penyelesaian jika ada dan jika tidak ada
penyelesaian bermakna F rupanya adalah fungsi sifar malar maka output yang betul adalah untuk melaporkan
bahawa tidak ada penyelesaian ini adalah masalah carian tak berstruktur dalam erti kata bahawa tidak ada
yang istimewa tentang F yang memudahkan pencarian penyelesaian ia bukan seperti kita mencari
melalui data yang sudah disusun atau yang telah dimuatkan ke dalam struktur data semacam itu yang memudahkan pencarian dan tidak ada janji pada
fungsi f yang mungkin membantu kita satu cara untuk memikirkannya ialah ia seperti mencari
nombor telefon tertentu dalam buku telefon berbanding mencari nama yang jauh lebih mudah dengan andaian nama telah
disusun mengikut abjad dalam istilah praktikal ia bukan benar-benar tentang mencari melalui data
yang kita cenderung mengatur dan menyimpan dengan cara yang memudahkan pencarian ia lebih mewakili pencarian
penyelesaian kepada persamaan yang rumit contohnya atau mungkin mencari kombinasi yang membuka
kunci sebagai catatan tambahan adalah munasabah untuk memikirkan masalah ini dalam konteks model pertanyaan tanpa mengira bagaimana kita mungkin
berasa tentang relevan praktikal model tersebut sudah tentu tidak ada oracle atau kotak hitam dalam kehidupan sebenar tetapi sehingga kita
tahu sebaliknya circuit Boolean yang rumit dan misteri agak seperti kotak
hitam sekarang jom kita fikir tentang algoritma untuk menyelesaikan masalah carian tak berstruktur ini dan kita akan melakukan ini
dalam model pertanyaan hanya untuk kesederhanaan jika kita mempunyai circuit Boolean untuk fungsi kita berbanding kotak hitam
maka kita masih boleh menjalankan algoritma pertanyaan padanya tetapi sudah tentu kita tidak boleh menolak kemungkinan bahawa beberapa algoritma baru
ditemui untuk masalah ini yang tidak berdasarkan membuat pertanyaan tetapi kita tidak akan membimbangkan diri kita dengan kemungkinan itu
pertama sedikit notasi jumlah keseluruhan rentetan input kepada fungsi f ialah 2 kepada
WEBVTT
n kecil di mana n kecil adalah panjang rentetan input kepada F dan selepas ini saya akan biarkan N besar menjadi nombor ini 2 kepada
n kecil agak biasa orang guna huruf besar seperti ini untuk menandakan dua kepada kuasa huruf kecil
versi huruf itu kita akan banyak bercakap tentang N besar jadi ini hanya akan
memudahkan dan ia akan membantu memastikan segala-galanya lebih kemas dan sekali lagi notasi ini berlaku untuk
keseluruhan pelajaran sekarang sudah tentu kita boleh menyelesaikan Masalah carian secara klasik dengan hanya
mengulang semua rentetan n bit yang mungkin dalam apa jua urutan yang kita pilih menilai F pada setiap satu daripada
mereka jika kita menemui penyelesaian pada bila-bila masa kita boleh berhenti tetapi dalam kes terburuk kita akan berakhir dengan menilai F pada setiap satu
rentetan input jadi ini memerlukan N bermaksud N besar
pertanyaan kita boleh memilih untuk mengukur kos pengiraan ini dengan cara yang berbeza bukan sahaja dari segi bilangan pertanyaan tetapi bilangan pertanyaan
mewakili berapa kali kita perlu menilai fungsi f dan adalah munasabah untuk mengharapkan bahawa penilaian f akan mendominasi kos
pengiraan ini ini sebenarnya adalah yang terbaik yang boleh kita lakukan dengan algoritma deterministik
dan sekali lagi ini dalam konteks model pertanyaan kalau kita dah pertanyakan setiap rentetan input
kecuali satu daripadanya dan F telah mengambil nilai sifar pada semuanya setakat ini bagaimana kita boleh pasti bahawa yang terakhir
rentetan itu bukan penyelesaian dan jawapannya ialah kita tak boleh jadi kita memang perlukan semua N pertanyaan dalam kes
terburuk kita juga boleh guna Kerawakan yang boleh menawarkan beberapa penambahbaikan kecil seperti mengurangkan
bilangan pertanyaan yang dijangka diperlukan untuk mencari penyelesaian apabila ada satu atau kita boleh secara berkesan menukar kebarangkalian ketepatan
dengan pengurangan dalam pertanyaan tetapi walau apa pun kita masih perlukan bilangan pertanyaan yang linear
dalam N jadi secara klasik kita perlukan bilangan pertanyaan yang linear bermaksud linear
dalam N besar algoritma Grover ialah algoritma kuantum untuk carian yang lebih baik ia hanya memerlukan bigo dari
punca kuasa dua N pertanyaan pertanyaan tersebut berlaku dalam superposisi jadi ia bukan ajaib tapi ia
adalah peningkatan yang ketara berbanding apa yang mungkin secara klasik dan inilah maksud kelebihan kuadratik
Adakah kelebihan kuadratik kuantum berbanding klasik ini boleh dijadikan kelebihan sebenar dalam erti kata praktikal
mungkin tidak dalam masa terdekat tapi pada masa hadapan siapa tahu tapi walaupun
algoritma Grover tidak pernah membawa kepada Kelebihan praktikal untuk pencarian ia tetap merupakan bahagian penting daripada
asas algoritma kuantum yang sangat berbaloi untuk difahami sebelum kita beralih ke algoritma Grover itu sendiri kita perlu
berbincang secara ringkas tentang apa yang dipanggil gate pertanyaan fasa banyak algoritma kuantum dalam model pertanyaan secara semula jadinya dinyatakan
menggunakan gate pertanyaan fasa dan kita akan lihat bahawa algoritma Grover adalah contoh
spesifik jom kita mulakan dengan pandangan pantas tentang gate pertanyaan biasa untuk fungsi f berbentuk
yang kita bincangkan gate pertanyaan UF ditakrifkan pada keadaan asas standard seperti yang ditunjukkan pada
skrin dan untuk superposisi keadaan asas standard tindakan ditentukan oleh kelinearan dan berbaloi mengingatkan
diri kita bahawa daripada circuit Boolean untuk f kita sebenarnya boleh membina circuit untuk operasi UF ini pada kos yang
linear dengan saiz circuit Boolean gate pertanyaan fasa untuk f sebaliknya yang akan kita tandakan dengan
nama ZF beroperasi seperti ini khususnya gate ini beroperasi pada
n qubit kecil berbanding n plus satu qubit kecil dan ia pada dasarnya hanya secara automatik menendang nilai fungsi
ke dalam fasa berbanding xoring nilai output ke atas qubit tambahan seperti yang kita ada untuk
UF jadi kalau kita fikir tentang apa yang berlaku apabila kita guna phase Kickback pada gate UF
kita pada dasarnya hanya melaksanakan ZF G kita perlukan keadaan minus dan ia kos satu
penilaian UF tetapi kita sebenarnya mendapat keadaan minus itu kembali dan kita boleh menggunakannya untuk yang seterusnya kalau nak atau kita
boleh buang sahaja jadi itulah gate pertanyaan fasa sekarang kalau kita hanya
diberi gate pertanyaan fasa ZF dan ini adalah satu-satunya cara kita mempunyai akses kepada fungsi f maka kita sebenarnya tidak boleh
mendapatkan semula gate UF tetapi jika kita mempunyai versi terkawal ZF maka kita boleh
membina gate UF dan saya akan tinggalkan yang satu itu untuk korang sebagai
latihan selain gate pertanyaan fasa untuk fungsi f kita juga akan memerlukan gate pertanyaan fasa untuk fungsi
atau nbit atau dengan kata lain fungsi yang mengambil nilai sifar apabila diberi rentetan l0o dan selainnya ia
mengambil nilai satu dan secara eksplisit cara zor berfungsi pada keadaan asas standard ditunjukkan
di sini pada skrin gate ini tidak mempunyai sebarang kebergantungan pada fungsi f jadi ia tidak memerlukan
sebarang pertanyaan dan satu cara kita boleh membina circuit kuantum yang melaksanakan operasi ini ialah dengan melakukan sesuatu
yang serupa dengan apa yang kita lakukan untuk fungsi f kecuali kita mulakan dengan circuit Boolean yang mengira fungsi atau pada
N Bit dan sekarang kita mempunyai gate-gate ini kita bersedia untuk beralih ke bahagian seterusnya
sekarang kita akan bincangkan algoritma Grover bermula dengan penerangan algoritma kita mulakan dengan memulakan
n qubit kecil masing-masing ke keadaan tambah atau dengan kata lain kita letakkan qubit ini ke dalam superposisi sama rata semua
rentetan binari dengan panjang n apa yang akan kita lakukan ialah secara berkesan memandu keadaan qubit ini
ke arah penyelesaian jadi adalah intuitif bahawa kita mulakan dalam keadaan ini kerana kita tidak tahu apa-apa tentang fungsi f lagi
pada ketika ini setiap rentetan sama kemungkinannya sebagai penyelesaian dan itu dicerminkan oleh fakta bahawa qubit ini berada dalam superposisi sama rata semua
rentetan dan kemudian kita ulang kita berulang kali guna operasi grover yang benar-benar merupakan teras
algoritma dan saya akan terangkannya dalam sebentar kita guna operasi ini sebanyak T kali di mana T adalah beberapa integer bukan negatif
tapi nombor ini sebenarnya tidak ditentukan oleh algoritma itu sendiri kita perlu memilih T entah bagaimana dan dalam bahagian seterusnya
kita akan bincangkan pilihan yang baik untuk T tetapi buat masa ini kita boleh fikir tentang bilangan iterasi t ini sebagai
sewenang-wenang dan akhirnya kita ukur dalam asas standard dan itu memberi kita
calon penyelesaian tidak ada jaminan bahawa ia adalah penyelesaian tetapi kalau kita pilih T dengan baik maka
kebarangkalian untuk mendapat penyelesaian boleh dijadikan besar dan inilah operasi grover
WEBVTT
itu sendiri yang kita namakan G ia adalah komposisi operasi semua padanya pada N qubit jadi ini adalah operasi N
qubit pertama kita mempunyai gate ZF atau dengan kata lain gate pertanyaan fasa untuk
fungsi input f diikuti dengan lapisan gate Hadamard dan kemudian kita mempunyai zor yang merupakan gate pertanyaan fasa untuk fungsi
atau dan akhirnya lapisan gate Hadamard yang lain jadi kita lihat bahawa satu iterasi dalam
langkah dua boleh dilaksanakan oleh circuit yang mempunyai bentuk seperti yang ditunjukkan di sini pada skrin dan di sini kita mempunyai empat qubit by the way
tetapi secara umum kita boleh mempunyai sebarang bilangan qubit perkara utama yang perlu diperhatikan di sini ialah kita perlukan satu pertanyaan f untuk melaksanakan G kita
perlukan satu pertanyaan untuk melaksanakan ZF dan tiada operasi lain yang mempunyai sebarang kebergantungan pada F jadi ia tidak memerlukan sebarang pertanyaan jadi nombor T ini yang
mewakili berapa kali kita guna G dalam langkah dua juga mewakili bilangan pertanyaan yang kita
perlukan inilah cara tipikal yang kita mungkin guna algoritma Grover tetapi ia tentu saja bukan satu-satunya cara seperti yang saya katakan
sebelumnya perkara pertama yang perlu kita lakukan ialah memilih T dan kita akan masuk ke dalam itu dalam bahagian seterusnya
untuk T yang kita pilih kita jalankan algoritma Grover untuk T iterasi dan kita mendapat calon penyelesaian
X tidak ada jaminan bahawa X benar-benar penyelesaian tetapi kita boleh belanjakan satu pertanyaan tambahan untuk menyemak jika kita mempunyai penyelesaian maka kita boleh
menghasilkan penyelesaian itu dan berhenti dan selainnya kita boleh sama ada cuba lagi mungkin dengan pilihan T yang berbeza
tetapi tidak semestinya atau kita boleh menyerah dan melaporkan bahawa tidak ada penyelesaian seperti yang saya katakan sebelumnya ini adalah
bukan satu-satunya cara algoritma mungkin digunakan tetapi ini adalah cara semula jadi untuk menerapkannya kepada masalah carian seterusnya kita akan lihat apa yang operasi grover
sebenarnya lakukan pada keadaan N qubit yang ia bertindak ke atasnya jom kita fikir tentang n qubit kita sebagai
membentuk satu daftar yang saya namakan Q hanya untuk memilih nama ingat apa yang kita lakukan pertama dalam
algoritma Grover ialah untuk meletakkan Q ke dalam superposisi seragam semua rentetan nbit dan kita melakukan itu dengan menggunakan gate Hadamard
pada n qubit dalam keadaan sifar semua kita kemudian mengulang operasi grover G dan kemudian
mengukur ia akan berguna untuk memisahkan set semua rentetan nbit kepada dua set a z dan
A1 a Zer mengandungi semua rentetan yang menyebabkan F menilai kepada sifar dan A1 mengandungi semua rentetan yang menyebabkan F
menilai kepada satu cara lain untuk mengatakannya ialah A1 mengandungi semua penyelesaian kepada masalah carian kita
sementara a z mengandungi semua bukan penyelesaian kita akan sangat berminat dengan
dua keadaan kuantum satu ialah superposisi seragam ke atas semua bukan penyelesaian itu adalah k a z dan
yang lain adalah seragam ke atas semua penyelesaian dan itu adalah Kat A1 saya perlu jelaskan bahawa definisi ini hanya berfungsi
apabila set ini tidak kosong kerana selainnya kita menjumlahkan sifar perkara dan membahagi dengan sifar dan semasa kita
melalui analisis algoritma Grover ini kita akan membuat andaian itu kita boleh dengan mudah mengetahui apa yang
algoritma Grover lakukan apabila f adalah sama ada fungsi sifar malar atau fungsi satu malar dengan memperlakukannya sebagai kes khas tetapi saya akan tinggalkan itu
untuk korang lakukan sendiri tidak menghairankan jika setiap rentetan adalah penyelesaian kita memang akan mendapatkan
penyelesaian apabila kita mengukur dan jika tidak ada penyelesaian maka kita tidak akan mendapatkannya kerana dalam kes itu tidak ada
yang ada tetapi untuk tujuan analisis ini kita akan mengandaikan bahawa kedua-dua set ini tidak kosong supaya definisi
dua keadaan ini masuk akal by the way ini adalah notasi yang agak biasa
bila-bila masa kita mempunyai set berhingga s yang tidak kosong kita boleh menulis c s untuk bermaksud superposisi seragam ke atas
unsur-unsur set itu sama seperti yang kita ada di sini jadi jom kita kumpulkan definisi ini seperti ini dan kita akan lihat bagaimana ia berkaitan
dengan algoritma Grover langkah pertama algoritma Grower ialah langkah permulaan yang meletakkan Q ke dalam superposisi seragam
ke atas semua rentetan nbit dan hanya untuk memberi keadaan ini nama yang mudah dikenali saya akan memanggilnya
kat u u adalah singkatan untuk seragam adalah penting untuk tujuan analisis bahawa kita pertama catat bahawa
keadaan seragam Catu ini terkandung dalam subruang yang dibentangkan oleh dua vektor K a0 dan K
A1 khususnya jika kita mengambil kombinasi linear dua keadaan ini yang ditunjukkan di sini pada skrin kita akan mendapat kat
U sekarang kunci kepada keseluruhan analisis ialah fakta bahawa keadaan Q kekal dalam
subruang dua dimensi ini tidak kira berapa kali kita guna operasi grover jadi segalanya akan bermuara
kepada apa yang berlaku dalam subruang dua dimensi sekarang jom kita lihat apa yang operasi grover lakukan dan khususnya apa yang ia
lakukan kepada vektor dalam subruang dua dimensi yang dibentangkan oleh kat a0 dan K
A1 adalah berguna untuk membayangkan bahawa g dibahagikan kepada dua bahagian satu bahagian ialah gate ZF
dan bahagian lain ialah gate zor yang diapit antara dua lapisan gate Hadamard
berikut ialah definisi ZF dari tadi dan adalah agak mudah dari definisi itu untuk melihat bahawa tindakannya
pada dua keadaan kita superposisi seragam bukan penyelesaian dan penyelesaian hanya meletakkan tanda tolak
di depan K A1 baik tidak ada yang berlaku kepada K a0 dan itu sahaja yang kita benar-benar perlu tahu
tentang ZF untuk tujuan analisis ini untuk bahagian kedua yang merupakan
gate Z or yang diapit antara dua lapisan gate Hadamard jom kita mulakan dengan mengingat semula cara zor ditakrifkan satu cara untuk menulisnya
adalah seperti yang ditunjukkan pada skrin ini adalah ungkapan yang sama seperti sebelumnya dan satu lagi cara untuk menyatakannya menggunakan notasi terus
adalah seperti ini dan korang boleh sahkan ungkapan ini hanya dengan memikirkan cara operasi pada
sebelah kanan bertindak pada keadaan asas standard khususnya ia tidak melakukan apa-apa pada keadaan sifar semua dan setiap
keadaan asas standard yang lain mendapat tanda tolak yang bersetuju dengan definisi Z
or jadi kalau kita menyelitkan operasi ini antara dua lapisan gate Hadamard maka kita mendapat ungkapan yang serupa kecuali
bahawa sebagai ganti keadaan asas standard sifar semua kita kini mempunyai sub posisi seragam kita k u dan itu kerana H tensor
n mengubah keadaan asas standard L sifar kepada k u dan juga H tensor n adalah konjugat transposnya sendiri jadi ia berfungsi dengan cara yang serupa
bertindak dari kanan pada bra berbanding kat dan sekarang kita akan mengetahui
apa yang G lakukan kepada dua vektor kita a0 dan A1 menggunakan fakta yang baru kita
perhatikan jom kita mulakan dengan a0 pertama jom kita gantikan ungkapan
yang kita peroleh untuk gate Z or yang diapit antara dua lapisan gate Hadamard seterusnya kita boleh menggunakan fakta bahawa ZF tidak melakukan apa-apa
kepada kat a z jadi kita boleh menyingkirkan operasi ZF dan sekarang menggunakan penerangan
WEBVTT
yang kita peroleh untuk gate Z or yang diapit antara dua lapisan gate Hadamard seterusnya kita boleh menggunakan fakta bahawa ZF tidak melakukan apa-apa
kepada kat a z jadi kita boleh menyingkirkan operasi ZF dan sekarang menggunakan penerangan
kat U yang kita ada di sini bersama fakta bahawa K a0 dan K A1 adalah vektor unit ortogon kita boleh mengira
hasil darab bra ini dan kat ini dan apa yang kita dapat ialah punca kuasa dua bilangan bukan penyelesaian
dibahagi dengan N kita boleh menggunakan fakta ini untuk menilai apa yang kita dapat dan dengan menggantikan ungkapan kita untuk kat U dan
mempermudah kita mendapat keputusan akhir yang ditunjukkan di sini pada skrin khususnya perhatikan bahawa
Vektor ini terkandung dalam subruang dua dimensi yang dibentangkan oleh K a0 dan K A1 seperti yang saya cadangkan sebelumnya dan
lebih-lebih lagi pekali kebetulannya adalah nombor nyata seperti selalu sahkan ini pada
kadar korang sendiri kalau korang nak buat tu saya cenderung melalui perkara-perkara seperti ini dengan cepat dalam video ini dengan
jangkaan bahawa korang akan jeda video untuk memberikan sedikit pemikiran kalau korang nak buat tu jadi jom kita kemas ini supaya
kita boleh simpan keputusan akhir untuk kemudian dan sekarang kita akan lakukan sesuatu yang serupa untuk vektor k
A1 kita boleh guna ungkapan G yang sama seperti sebelumnya dan kali ini gate ZF menyuntikkan
tanda tolak yang di sini dicerminkan oleh fakta bahawa kita telah menukar dua sebutan dalam operasi dalam
kurungan kita kemudian meneruskan dengan cara yang sangat serupa dan keputusan akhir adalah serupa kecuali dua pekali
ditukar dan kita sekarang mempunyai tanda tolak di depan salah satunya yang hanya cara algebra berfungsi dan sekali lagi korang
boleh semak ini pada kadar korang sendiri perhatikan bahawa sekali lagi kita mempunyai kombinasi linear nyata dua vektor kita K a0 dan
K A1 kita akan kemas yang ini juga dan kita akan menyatukan keputusan akhir dengan yang satu lagi dan sekarang kita boleh lihat bagaimana G
bertindak pada subruang yang dibentangkan oleh dua vektor kita satu cara untuk melakukan itu ialah menyatakannya dari segi matriks 2x2 M yang
ditunjukkan di sini pada skrin dan hanya untuk menjelaskan apa yang kita lakukan di sini ialah kita mengaitkan baris pertama dan
Lajur pertama dengan K a0 dan baris dan lajur kedua dengan Kat A1 setakat ini dalam siri ini kita
hanya guna matriks untuk menerangkan cara operasi berfungsi pada keadaan asas standard tetapi adalah biasa untuk guna matriks
untuk menerangkan tindakan peta linear pada set vektor yang berbeza bukan sahaja keadaan asas standard dan di sini kita bercakap tentang apa yang operasi G lakukan
kepada vektor K a0 dan K A1 kita boleh katakan lebih banyak tentang apa yang G lakukan kepada vektor dalam
rentangan K a0 dan K A1 kalau kita lihat lebih dekat pada Matriks M ini dan khususnya apa yang kita akan temui ialah
bahawa m adalah Matriks putaran bermaksud bahawa tindakannya pada ruang dua dimensi ini boleh digambarkan sebagai putaran oleh beberapa
sudut tetap ada beberapa cara berbeza untuk melihat ini dan salah satunya ialah untuk memerhatikan
bahawa Matriks M ini boleh dinyatakan sebagai kuasa dua matriks yang kelihatan agak lebih mudah itu mungkin sukar untuk dikesan kalau
kita hanya melihat M dengan sendirinya tetapi ini bukan sesuatu yang kita perlu temui sendiri kita hanya perlu mengesahkannya dan kita boleh melakukan itu dengan hanya
mengkuasaduakan Matriks di sebelah kanan satu lagi cara untuk menulis Matriks di sebelah kanan tidak termasuk kuasa dua adalah
ditunjukkan pada skrin dan ini adalah cara tipikal untuk menerangkan putaran oleh sudut Theta yang diberikan sebagai
matriks sudut tepat yang kita putar kebetulannya adalah songsang sinus punca kuasa dua bilangan
penyelesaian dibahagi dengan N dan by the way kerana ini adalah kali pertama kita melihatnya izinkan saya jelaskan bahawa
sudut ini sangat penting ia akan terus muncul semasa kita teruskan dengan
analisis ini argumen songsang sinus adalah nombor antara 0 dan 1 dan khususnya cara kita
mentafsir songsang sinus di sini ialah ia adalah sudut antara 0 dan Pi / 2 yang memberi kita argumen apabila kita mengambil
sinus jadi itulah satu cara untuk memikirkan Matriks yang kita kuasaduakan untuk mendapat
M dan kerana mengkuasaduakan Matriks adalah perkara yang sama dengan menggunakannya dua kali kita lihat bahawa M boleh ditulis secara alternatif sebagai
putaran bukan oleh sudut theta tetapi oleh dua * Theta kerana dengan mengkuasadua kita memutar oleh sudut theta
dua kali cara berbeza untuk mengesahkan semua ini by the way sekiranya ia membantu ialah untuk mulakan dengan ungkapan akhir M ini
dan guna formula sudut ganda dari trigonometri untuk mendapatkan ungkapan asal
M dan inilah ungkapan M yang menerangkan tindakan yang g ada pada Subruang yang Dibentangkan oleh K a0 dan K A1 yang
akan paling berguna ke depan sekarang kembali kepada algoritma Grover itu sendiri setelah
langkah permulaan tetapi sebelum kita melakukan sebarang penggunaan G keadaan daftar N Qubit kita Q adalah Catu iaitu
superposisi seragam ke atas semua rentetan nbit dan di sini kita mempunyai ungkapan yang sama kat u dari segi K a0 dan
K A1 seperti sebelumnya tetapi sekarang kita telah mengenal pasti sudut Theta ini kita nampak bahawa
kita boleh menulis k u secara alternatif sebagai kosinus Theta * k a 0 tambah sinus Theta * K
A1 itu jelas untuk pekali K A1 dan untuk pekali yang lain kita hanya perlu memerhatikan bahawa saiz a0 tambah
saiz A1 adalah N dan kemudian kita boleh mendapatkannya dari beberapa trigonometri asas jadi itulah keadaan yang kita
mulakan dan kali pertama kita guna G kita memutar oleh sudut 2 * Theta jadi jumlah sudut menjadi 3 *
Theta dan kalau kita guna G lagi sudut meningkat kepada 5 Theta kerana kita secara berkesan telah memutar oleh tambahan
sudut 2 Theta dan seterusnya jadi selepas T penggunaan G kita boleh mewakili
keadaan yang kita dapat seperti yang ditunjukkan pada skrin di mana sudut keadaan kita adalah sama dengan 2T + 1 * Theta itu 2 * Theta
untuk setiap penggunaan G bersama tambahan Theta kerana itulah keadaan yang kita mulakan
kita juga boleh memikirkan tindakan operasi grover dalam istilah geometri dan ini membantu menerangkan bagaimana
ia berfungsi dan mengapa kesannya adalah untuk memutar keadaan daftar Q inilah idea utamanya operasi grover
adalah komposisi dua bahagian yang telah kita kenal pasti satu ialah ZF dan yang lain ialah z or yang dihantar antara
dua lapisan gate Hadamard dua bahagian ini adalah
pantulan dan apabila kita mengarang dua Pantulan kita mendapat putaran jadi jom kita lihat bagaimana ini berfungsi dalam
butiran yang lebih terperinci pertama jom kita fokus pada ZF dan kita akan membatasi perhatian kita kepada
subruang dua dimensi yang sama yang kita bincangkan bermaksud yang dibentangkan oleh kat a0 dan Kat
A1 seperti yang kita sudah perhatikan tindakan ZF pada ruang ini agak mudah ia tidak melakukan apa-apa
kepada kat a z dan ia meletakkan tanda tolak di depan K A1 ini adalah pantulan dan khususnya
WEBVTT
ia adalah pantulan tentang garis selari dengan K a0 yang akan kita panggil L1 hanya untuk memberinya
nama untuk melihat mengapa ia adalah pantulan ia membantu untuk melukis gambar di sini kita mempunyai dua vektor K
a0 dan K A1 yang merupakan vektor unit ortogon dan kita boleh memikirkan skrin sebagai terdiri daripada semua
kombinasi linear nyata dua vektor ini jadi bulatan mewakili semua vektor unit yang pekalinya dari
dua vektor ini adalah nombor nyata inilah garis L1 yang selari dengan K a0 dan kalau kita mempertimbangkan beberapa
Vektor s sewenang-wenang pada bulatan ini maka kesan penggunaan ZF ialah untuk memantulkan tentang garis ini seperti yang digambarkan pada
skrin hanya kerana kita tidak melakukan apa-apa kepada k a z dan kita meletakkan tanda tolak di depan K
A1 dalam kes khas bahawa s adalah k a sifar contohnya tidak ada yang berlaku apabila kita melakukan pantulan ini dan apabila s adalah
K A1 pantulan membawa kita sepanjang jalan ke negatif K A1 dan itu konsisten dengan tindakan ZF jadi ZF adalah
pantulan yang boleh digambarkan seperti yang kita ada di sini bahagian kedua G yang merupakan z or
yang diapit antara dua lapisan gate Hadamard boleh dinyatakan sebagai 2 * K Bru tolak matriks identiti seperti yang kita
sudah lihat dan sekali lagi ini adalah pantulan kali ini tentang garis L2 selari dengan k u berbanding K
a0 kita boleh menggambarkan operasi ini dengan cara yang serupa dengan ZF inilah vektor k
secara hipotesis jadi inilah garis L2 selari dengan K dan sekali lagi tindakan pada Vektor S sewenang-wenang adalah untuk memantulkannya
tentang garis yang ialah L2 dalam kes ini
dan akhirnya seperti yang saya sebutkan sebelumnya bila-bila masa kita mengarang dua Pantulan kita mendapat putaran dan khususnya ia adalah
putaran sebanyak dua kali sudut antara garis pantulan jadi jom kita lukis gambar yang serupa
dengan apa yang kita ada sebelumnya inilah garis pantulan yang mempunyai sudut Theta antara
mereka dan kalau kita ambil beberapa Vektor s sewenang-wenang dipantulkan di sekitar garis pertama L1 dan
kemudian dipantulkan tentang garis kedua L2 maka kesan bersih adalah untuk memutar vektor s oleh sudut dua kali Theta
dan ini adalah sesuatu yang benar secara umum dan korang boleh mencubanya pada beberapa contoh tambahan sendiri untuk melihat bahawa ini memang cara ia
berfungsi bagaimanapun semoga ini membantu korang mendapat sedikit intuisi tentang mengapa operasi grover mempunyai kesan memutar
vektor seterusnya kita akan beralih kepada isu memilih bilangan iterasi T dalam algoritma Grover
jom kita mulakan dengan memikirkan bagaimana analisis yang telah kita lihat setakat ini yang mendedahkan apa yang operasi grover lakukan
apabila kita menerapkannya berulang kali kepada superposisi seragam berkaitan dengan tugas yang kita harap untuk diselesaikan iaitu mencari penyelesaian kepada masalah carian kita
atau dengan kata lain mana-mana rentetan yang terkandung dalam set A1 secara ringkas kita pada dasarnya akan menetapkan
Sasaran dan kemudian mengetahui berapa kali untuk menerapkan operasi grover untuk mendekati sasaran itu
pertama jom kita bayangkan bahawa kita mempunyai sebarang keadaan yang merupakan kombinasi linear dua vektor kita K a0 dan K
A1 kalau kita melakukan pengukuran asas standard pada keadaan ini kita akan mendapat hasil dalam set A1 yang merupakan
set penyelesaian kepada masalah carian kita dengan kebarangkalian sama dengan nilai mutlak kuasa dua bagi pekali yang kita ada untuk K A1 dan untuk
vektor yang ditunjukkan pada skrin pekali itu adalah beta ini adalah intuitif kalau kita mengukur keadaan K a0
kita akan mendapat bukan penyelesaian rawak dan kalau kita mengukur K A1 kita akan mendapat penyelesaian rawak jadi kalau kita mengukur keadaan ini
di sini kita akan mendapat bukan penyelesaian rawak dengan kebarangkalian nilai mutlak Alpha kuasa dua dan penyelesaian rawak
dengan kebarangkalian nilai mutlak beta kuasa dua tetapi kita juga boleh ambil masa untuk mengiranya di sini ialah keadaan yang ditulis
supaya kita dapat melihat apa yang entri vektor ini untuk keadaan asas standard jadi kalau kita mengukur ini adalah
kebarangkalian untuk mendapatkan setiap kemungkinan hasil dan untuk mendapat kebarangkalian mendapat penyelesaian kita jumlahkan
kebarangkalian untuk semua kemungkinan penyelesaian yang memberi kita nilai mutlak beta kuasa dua seperti
yang dijangkakan sekarang kita telah menganalisis apa yang berlaku apabila kita menjalankan algoritma Grover untuk T iterasi kita mendapat keadaan yang
ditunjukkan di sini pada skrin jadi kerana pekali K A1 adalah S
dari 2T + 1 * Theta di mana sekali lagi inilah sudut Theta yang sangat penting ini kita
akan melihat penyelesaian dengan kebarangkalian sin^2 dari 2T +1 *
Theta kita ingin menjadikan kebarangkalian itu besar idealnya sedekat mungkin dengan satu jadi semasa kita memutar vektor keadaan
dengan mengulang G kita akan memikirkan K A1 sebagai keadaan sasaran dan kita akan cuba
memilih T supaya kita mendarat dekat dengan keadaan ini dan semasa kita melakukan ini adalah baik untuk diingat bahawa kita juga ingin
meminimumkan T kerana itulah bilangan pertanyaan yang perlu kita buat jadi kalau kita ingin menjadikan ini
kebarangkalian mendekati satu dan meminimumkan T adalah masuk akal untuk cuba menjadikan sudut vektor keadaan kita dekat dengan Pi / 2 kerana
itulah sudut terkecil yang menjadikan kuasa dua sinus besar jadi ia pada dasarnya adalah peluang pertama kita untuk menjadikan kebarangkalian besar semasa kita
memutar vektor keadaan sekarang kita tidak semestinya boleh mencapai sudut pi atas 2 ini tepat kerana T mestilah
integer tetapi kalau kita fikir tentangnya secara anggaran dan selesaikan untuk t seolah-olah ia adalah ketaksamaan maka kita nampak bahawa secara idealnya
memilih T sebagai pi atas 4 * Theta tolak 12 adalah
masuk akal tetapi sudah tentu T mestilah integer bukan negatif jadi apa yang akan kita lakukan ialah mengambil
integer terdekat kepada apa yang kita bayangkan sebagai nilai ideal ini yang merupakan lantai pi dibahagi 4 *
Theta mengambil lantai by the way hanya bermaksud bahawa kita buang bahagian pecahan apa-apa jadi dengan kata lain ia adalah yang terbesar
integer yang kurang daripada atau sama dengan apa sahaja yang kita ambil lantainya menurut ungkapan ini kalau
nilai ideal kebetulannya adalah separuh jalan antara integer kita akan bundar ke atas tetapi itu sebenarnya tidak akan penting sama sekali untuk
tujuan pelajaran ini jadi ke depan kita akan fokus pada pilihan T yang tertentu ini
tetapi ada satu lagi pertimbangan penting yang perlu kita buat iaitu spesifikasi T ini bergantung
kepada berapa banyak penyelesaian yang ada kerana sudut Theta bergantung pada bilangan
penyelesaian selepas ini saya akan guna huruf s untuk merujuk kepada bilangan penyelesaian atau dengan kata lain saiz
set a satu hanya untuk kemudahan bagaimanapun intinya ialah
ungkapan kita untuk T nilai yang kita hipotesiskan sepatutnya baik bergantung kepada Theta dan Theta bergantung kepada S yang merupakan
WEBVTT
saiz set A1 ini bukan masalah kalau kita tahu terlebih dahulu berapa banyak penyelesaian yang ada tetapi
kalau kita tidak tahu berapa banyak penyelesaian yang ada terlebih dahulu kita tidak tahu apa itu Theta jadi kita tidak boleh pilih T seperti ini
dan kita perlu buat sesuatu yang berbeza saya akan kembali kepada situasi di mana kita tidak tahu s sebentar lagi tetapi untuk
mulakan jom kita fokus pada situasi di mana kita tahu berapa banyak penyelesaian yang ada bermula dengan carian unik
di mana ada dijamin satu penyelesaian unik yang kita cari
saya sebut masalah carian unik sebagai contoh masalah pertanyaan dalam pelajaran
lima input adalah fungsi f dari nbit kepada satu bit ada satu
rentetan n bit yang unik yang menyebabkan F menilai kepada satu dan matlamatnya adalah untuk menghasilkan rentetan itu jadi
ini bersamaan dengan masalah carian tak berstruktur yang kita bincangkan tetapi dengan janji bahawa ada tepat satu penyelesaian dan sebenarnya ini adalah
satu-satunya versi masalah carian yang Grover pertimbangkan dalam kertas asalnya tahun 1996 yang memperkenalkan algoritma Grover
untuk carian Unik kita mempunyai bahawa s sama dengan 1 dan oleh itu sudut Theta yang penting ini adalah sama dengan songsang sinus
punca kuasa dua 1 N apabila N besar nilai ini adalah lebih kurang punca 1/ N dan
itu kerana untuk sudut yang semakin kecil fungsi sinus mula kelihatan semakin seperti fungsi identiti
kalau kita gantikan anggaran itu ke dalam pilihan kita untuk T kita nampak bahawa t adalah lebih kurang lantai
pi atas 4 * punca kuasa dua N itu bagus kerana kita sedang menuju untuk guna Big O dari punca kuasa dua N
pertanyaan walaupun pada ketika ini kita belum lihat dengan tepat seberapa baik algoritma
berfungsi jom kita lihat contoh di mana N besar adalah 128 yang adalah 2 ^ 7 jadi
fungsi f kita adalah dari tujuh bit kepada satu bit dan kita mengandaikan bahawa ada penyelesaian unik tetapi untuk mengetahui betapa
baiknya algoritma berfungsi kita hanya perlu membimbangkan diri kita dengan sudut Theta yang boleh kita kirakan ia adalah
lebih kurang 0.0885 radian yang sedikit lebih daripada 5° dan kalau kita masukkan nilai itu ke dalam
ungkapan kita untuk T kita mendapat lapan jadi kita fikir tentang apa yang berlaku apabila kita mencari penyelesaian unik daripada 128
kemungkinan menggunakan lapan pertanyaan kita boleh melukis gambar untuk menggambarkan bagaimana keadaan berubah dari masa ke
masa semasa kita melakukan iterasi operasi grover seperti sebelumnya kita mempunyai keadaan K
a0 dan K A1 dan dalam kes tertentu ini bermaksud carian unik kita mempunyai bahawa Kat A1 sebenarnya adalah keadaan asas standard
yang sepadan dengan penyelesaian unik apa pun ia K a0 adalah superposisi seragam ke atas semua
rentetan selain penyelesaian unik inilah superposisi seragam ke atas semua rentetan yang kita
boleh tulis sebagai kosinus Theta K a0 tambah sinus Theta K A1 dan masuk akal bahawa K a0
dan K U adalah dekat dalam kes ini kerana seperti yang kita perhatikan sebentar tadi K a0 adalah
hampir superposisi seragam ke atas semua rentetan hanya ada satu rentetan yang hilang dan itu adalah penyelesaian unik menggunakan G lagi memutar oleh
tambahan 2 Theta jadi inilah tempat kita setelah dua iterasi inilah tiga 4 5 6 7 dan 8
dan sekarang kita nampak bahawa kita agak dekat dengan Kat A1 jadi kalau kita berhenti dan mengukur pada ketika ini kita akan cukup berkemungkinan untuk mendapat
penyelesaian unik dan sebenarnya dalam kes ini hanya ada lebih kurang peluang setengah peratus yang kita tidak mendapat penyelesaian unik
Sebaliknya kalau kita terus menggunakan operasi grover lebih daripada lapan kali yang disyorkan
maka kebarangkalian untuk mendapat penyelesaian akan turun semula dan lama kelamaan ia akan berayun semasa keadaan pergi mengelilingi
bulatan jadi adalah penting bahawa kita hentikan iterasi pada masa yang tepat kalau kita ingin berjaya dengan kebarangkalian yang tinggi
jom kita fikir tentang kebarangkalian bahawa pilihan kita untuk T mendedahkan penyelesaian unik secara lebih umum untuk nilai N yang berbeza
kita akan tulis pn1 untuk menandakan kebarangkalian algoritma Grover berjaya menemui penyelesaian unik
untuk setiap nilai N yang mungkin satu bermaksud satu penyelesaian dan kita akan memperluas notasi ini kepada bilangan penyelesaian lain
tidak lama lagi inilah jadual kebarangkalian ini untuk kuasa dua yang kecil ia bermula dengan N sama 2 dan
kebarangkalian adalah 1 12 yang tidak begitu baik tetapi kemudian untuk N sama 4 kebarangkalian adalah tepat satu jadi ia sebenarnya berfungsi
dengan sempurna dalam kes ini ia adalah latihan yang bagus by the way untuk secara eksplisit melalui cara dua kes ini berfungsi
khususnya kes bahawa N adalah sama dengan empat dalam kes itu kita mencari satu penyelesaian daripada empat kemungkinan
kita hanya perlukan satu pertanyaan dan ia berfungsi dengan sempurna apabila N semakin besar kita memang melihat beberapa turun naik kebarangkalian pergi
naik dan turun sedikit tetapi ia kelihatan semakin dekat dengan satu dan memang itu benar ia boleh dibuktikan
secara analitik bahawa kebarangkalian sentiasa sekurang-kurangnya 1 - 1 / N jadi itu bagus
algoritma tidak sempurna kita tidak dijamin mendapat penyelesaian tetapi ia cukup berkemungkinan terutamanya untuk nilai N yang besar
serta anomali yang sangat menarik yang berlaku apabila N sama dengan 4
saya juga perlu jelaskan bahawa kita sentiasa boleh menjalankan keseluruhan algoritma termasuk pengukuran sebanyak kali yang kita pilih dan kalau mana-mana satu daripada larian
berjaya kita akan mendapat penyelesaian jadi kalau kebarangkalian ini tidak cukup baik kita boleh dengan mudah meningkatkannya dengan hanya menjalankan
algoritma lagi sebenarnya walaupun kebarangkalian ini semua sama dengan 1/2 contohnya kita masih akan mempunyai
algoritma carian yang berguna sekarang jom kita pertimbangkan apa yang berlaku apabila terdapat berbilang
Penyelesaian kita akan mulakan dengan contoh yang serupa dengan yang sebelumnya sekali lagi N adalah sama dengan 128 tetapi kali ini
bilangan penyelesaian s adalah empat berbanding 1 sekali lagi kita boleh mengira Theta dan T dan
kita mendapat bahawa Theta adalah lebih kurang 01777 atau sedikit lebih daripada 10° dan T adalah
empat kali ini jadi sudutnya adalah lebih kurang dua kali nilai dari contoh sebelumnya dan T adalah separuh daripada apa yang ia
adalah kita boleh lukis gambar seperti sebelumnya inilah tempat kita
mulakan inilah satu iterasi dua tiga dan empat kali ini kita sangat dekat dengan kat
A1 dan kebarangkalian untuk mendapat penyelesaian kali ini rupanya lebih daripada
99.9% tetapi kalau kita tidak tahu lebih baik dan kita fikir bahawa hanya ada satu penyelesaian kita akan ambil T sebagai 8 seperti
sebelumnya kita akan putar hampir sepanjang jalan ke negatif K a0 dan itu akan membawa kepada kebarangkalian yang sangat kecil
kejayaan jadi itulah contoh lanjutan yang menunjukkan bahawa ada pilihan T yang baik dan pilihan T yang buruk dan di sini kita nampak
WEBVTT
bahawa pilihan yang baik untuk S sama 1 rupanya adalah pilihan yang sangat buruk untuk S sama 4 tetapi dengan mengandaikan bahawa kita memang tahu s terlebih
dahulu dan kita memilih T mengikut spesifikasi kita maka rupanya algoritma Grover akan menemui penyelesaian
dengan kebarangkalian sekurang-kurangnya 1 - x atas N dan kerap kali ia akan jauh lebih besar daripada itu ia juga sekurang-kurangnya s Atas N tetapi
itu sebenarnya jauh kurang menarik apa yang lebih menarik ialah apabila pecahan s Atas N semakin kecil sempadan
pada kebarangkalian kejayaan semakin dekat dengan satu sekarang seperti yang saya sudah ceritakan beberapa
kali bilangan T mewakili bukan sahaja bilangan iterasi operasi grover yang kita lakukan tetapi juga bilangan
pertanyaan yang kita buat jadi bagaimana nombor ini bergantung kepada s dan
N pertama jom kita mulakan dengan fakta bahawa songsang sinus X sentiasa sekurang-kurangnya X dengan syarat bahawa X adalah antara Z dan 1
itu agak mudah untuk ditunjukkan kalau korang kebetulan tahu siri tailor untuk fungsi songsang sinus tetapi ada cara lain untuk menganalisanya dan kita hanya
akan menerima ini sebagai diberikan kerana ia benar itu bermaksud bahawa Theta adalah sekurang-kurangnya punca kuasa dua s/
N dan akibatnya T adalah paling banyak punca kuasa dua / 4 * punca kuasa dua N /
s jadi itu sebenarnya lebih baik daripada Big O dari punca N semakin besar s
berbanding N semakin sedikit pertanyaan yang perlu kita buat dan dalam satu cara ia tidak menghairankan bahawa pecahan ini muncul
seperti ini memandangkan bahawa salingannya mentakrifkan Theta dan pada akhir hari Theta adalah benar-benar satu-satunya yang penting untuk
analisis ini seperti yang baru kita lihat algoritma Grover berfungsi dengan baik apabila kita tahu
terlebih dahulu berapa banyak penyelesaian yang ada tetapi bagaimana kalau kita tidak tahu berapa banyak penyelesaian yang ada
ada satu pendekatan yang agak mudah dan itu adalah untuk hanya memilih bilangan iterasi
secara rawak dan khususnya memilih T secara seragam rawak antara satu dan lantai pi atas 4 * punca N rupanya
adalah cara yang agak baik untuk melakukan ini hujung atas julat ini adalah lebih kurang bilangan pertanyaan yang kita akan pilih untuk carian Unik dan sebenarnya
ia adalah tepat bilangan yang betul dalam kebanyakan kes ini adalah apabila sudut Theta adalah sekecil yang mungkin tidak termasuk
kes remeh apabila tidak ada penyelesaian idea di sini ialah bukannya membidik tepat vektor keadaan kita pada
K A1 seperti yang kita lakukan apabila kita tahu berapa banyak penyelesaian yang ada kita pada dasarnya memutar oleh sudut rawak seolah-olah kita
hanya memberi vektor keadaan putaran rawak kalau kebetulan hanya ada satu penyelesaian maka putaran rawak kita boleh mendorong
vektor keadaan dekat dengan K A1 tetapi ia mungkin juga hanya pergi separuh jalan ke sana dan kalau kebetulan ada banyak penyelesaian maka
putaran rawak kita berpotensi menghantar vektor keadaan mengelilingi bulatan beberapa kali jadi kita tidak mengharapkan ini untuk mendedahkan
penyelesaian dengan kebarangkalian yang dekat dengan satu tetapi peluang bahawa ini membawa kepada penyelesaian kalau ada satu rupanya
agak baik ia sentiasa sekurang-kurangnya 40% sebenarnya itu tidak jelas tetapi ia adalah
kes ia tentu tidak mengejutkan walaupun kerana sudut yang benar-benar rawak akan mempunyai 50% peluang menemui
penyelesaian bagaimanapun 40% tidak buruk dan ingat bahawa kita sentiasa boleh meningkatkan kebarangkalian menemui penyelesaian dengan
mengulangi proses memilih T secara bebas setiap kali dengan melakukan ini peluang tidak
menemui penyelesaian apabila ada satu menurun secara eksponen dalam bilangan kali kita ulang jadi kalau kita ingin 99% %
peluang menemui penyelesaian apa yang boleh kita lakukan ialah menjalankan pendekatan mudah ini 10 kali sekali lagi dengan t dipilih secara bebas setiap
kali secara semula jadinya kalau kita tidak menemui penyelesaian kita keluarkan tiada Penyelesaian kalau tidak ada penyelesaian
kita tidak akan menemuinya dan jadi dalam kes itu kita akan sentiasa mengeluarkan jawapan yang betul iaitu tiada Penyelesaian kalau ada penyelesaian kita
mungkin gagal menemui satu dan tersilap mengisytiharkan bahawa tidak ada Penyelesaian tetapi kebarangkalian berlakunya itu boleh dibuat sangat kecil
kita juga ada seperti yang saya sebutkan beberapa ketika tadi bahawa ini memerlukan bilangan pertanyaan atau penilaian f yang merupakan Big O dari punca
N jadi menggunakan algoritma Grover kita masih boleh menyelesaikan masalah carian dengan kebarangkalian tinggi dengan Big O dari punca N
pertanyaan walaupun kalau kita tidak tahu terlebih dahulu berapa banyak penyelesaian yang ada ada juga
pendekatan yang lebih canggih yang boleh membawa kepada pengurangan dalam bilangan pertanyaan apabila bilangan penyelesaian berkembang saya tidak akan terangkannya dalam
butiran walaupun dan sebaliknya saya hanya akan fokus pada idea utama kita mulakan dengan T besar sama dengan
satu kita kemudian menjalankan algoritma Grover untuk bilangan iterasi rawak tetapi di mana had atas adalah T jadi kali pertama kita
sampai ke langkah dua kita akan menjalankan algoritma Grover dengan satu iterasi tetapi T akan
berkembang kalau kita menemui penyelesaian maka kita keluarkan penyelesaian itu dan kita berhenti dan kalau kita tidak menemui penyelesaian kita jadikan t
lebih besar dan cuba lagi dan pada suatu ketika sebelum T menjadi terlalu besar kita akan menamatkan proses dan
kita akan isytiharkan bahawa tidak ada penyelesaian ia adalah idea asas yang sama seperti yang kita ada dalam pendekatan mudah di mana kita
memberi vektor keadaan putaran rawak pada dasarnya tetapi di sini kita mulakan dengan putaran yang lebih ringan dahulu di mana T adalah
kecil sekiranya ada banyak Penyelesaian dengan cara ini kita tidak akan bazir pertanyaan dengan membuat keadaan pergi mengelilingi
dan mengelilingi bulatan dengan berputar terlalu kuat tetapi kalau ia tidak berfungsi bermakna kita tidak menemui penyelesaian kita cuba lagi
tetapi kita berputar sedikit lebih kuat atau berpotensi sedikit lebih kuat untuk menjadikan ini berfungsi kadar
peningkatan T mesti dipilih dengan teliti dan satu cara untuk menjadikannya berfungsi ialah menggantikan T dengan siling 54s kali T
Jadi T meningkat secara eksponen dan secara intuitif kita boleh memikirkannya sebagai berputar 25% lebih keras setiap
kali dan adalah penting untuk analisis bahawa t meningkat secara eksponen seperti ini mengapa 54s korang mungkin tanya baik ia adalah
hanya nombor yang berfungsi dan sebenarnya ada julat nilai yang berfungsi tetapi dua tidak berfungsi contohnya menggandakan T
setiap kali adalah peningkatan yang terlalu cepat untuk mengambil penuh keuntungan daripada manfaat putaran yang lebih ringan bagaimanapun tujuan kaedah yang lebih
canggih ini ialah ia memberikan sempadan asimtotik yang sama pada bilangan pertanyaan yang kita perlukan seperti yang kita ada sebelumnya
Big O dari punca kuasa dua N / s tetapi kita tidak perlu tahu terlebih dahulu berapa banyak penyelesaian yang ada dan by the way
kita boleh hentikan proses ini apabila T mencapai punca N jadi kalau tidak ada penyelesaian kita akan mencapai kesimpulan itu selepas bigo
dari punca N pertanyaan dan itulah cara kita boleh memilih bilangan iterasi dalam algoritma Grover untuk menyimpulkan pelajaran saya akan
buat hanya beberapa catatan ringkas tentang algoritma Grover pertama dalam model pertanyaan
algoritma Grover adalah asimtotiknya optimum apa yang dimaksudkan ialah ia tidak mungkin untuk menghasilkan
algoritma pertanyaan untuk menyelesaikan masalah carian atau malah masalah carian unik khususnya yang menggunakan
lebih sedikit daripada Big O dari punca N pertanyaan dalam kes terburuk secara asimtotiknya itu adalah sesuatu yang boleh dibuktikan secara ketat
WEBVTT
dan sebenarnya ada berbilang bukti yang diketahui tentang fakta ini menariknya ini diketahui
bahkan sebelum algoritma Grover ditemui algoritma Grover memadankan sempadan bawah yang sudah diketahui pada bilangan
pertanyaan yang diperlukan dari masa ke masa orang memang menghasilkan pendekatan yang mereka percaya adalah secara asimtotiknya
lebih baik daripada algoritma Grover tetapi sentiasa ada sama ada kesilapan atau andaian tentang fungsi f dan
cara ia boleh diakses atau beberapa isu bermasalah lain yang menjadikan tuntutan itu salah kalau korang bekerja dengan betul
dalam model pertanyaan korang tidak boleh mengalahkan algoritma Grover untuk carian tak berstruktur kedua algoritma Grover adalah
cukup luas boleh diguna pakai dalam erti kata bahawa peningkatan kelajuan punca kuasa dua yang algoritma Grover tawarkan untuk masalah carian tak berstruktur boleh
diperoleh dalam pelbagai tetapan yang berbeza contohnya kadang-kadang adalah mungkin untuk guna algoritma Grover pada
atas algoritma lain untuk mendapat peningkatan kuadratik melebihi prestasi algoritma itu algoritma Grover juga
agak kerap digunakan sebagai sub rutin di dalam algoritma kuantum lain sebagai satu contoh mudah kita
boleh guna algoritma Grover untuk mendapat kelebihan kuadratik berbanding algoritma klasik untuk masalah minimum yang saya sebut dalam
pelajaran lima dan akhirnya teknik yang digunakan dalam algoritma Grover di mana kita mempunyai dua
Pantulan yang dikarang dan diulang untuk memutar Vektor Keadaan Kuantum boleh digeneralisasikan dalam cara yang agak
utama contohnya ialah teknik yang dikenali sebagai amplifikasi amplitud di mana proses
yang mengeneralisasikan algoritma Grover boleh diterapkan kepada algoritma kuantum lain untuk pada dasarnya meningkatkan kebarangkalian kejayaannya secara kuadratik lebih cepat daripada
yang mungkin secara klasik dan teknik itu mempunyai aplikasi yang luas dalam algoritma kuantum jadi mungkin benar bahawa
algoritma Grover tidak mungkin membawa kepada Kelebihan Kuantum praktikal pada bila-bila masa jika pernah tetapi algoritma Grover adalah
tanpa keraguan algoritma kuantum yang penting secara fundamental dan boleh digunakan secara luas dan ia mewakili teknik yang lebih umum yang mempunyai banyak
kegunaan dan itulah sahaja untuk pelajaran ini dan untuk unit siri ini yang berkaitan dengan algoritma Kuantum
kita bincangkan model pertanyaan dan cara kita boleh menghubungkannya kepada model pengiraan yang lebih standard bersama
beberapa konsep asas lain tentang cara kita boleh mengukur kos pengkomputeran kita kemudian membincangkan anggaran fasa
dan pemfaktoran dan kemudian akhirnya algoritma Grover seperti yang saya sudah cadangkan
ada banyak lagi yang perlu dipelajari tentang algoritma kuantum tetapi dalam siri ini kita akan beralih ke topik yang berbeza dalam unit seterusnya khususnya kita akan
lihat formulasi umum maklumat kuantum di mana keadaan kuantum diwakili oleh matriks sejenis
tertentu yang dikenali sebagai matriks ketumpatan seperti yang akan kita lihat formulasi ini rupanya sangat berguna dan sememangnya
penting untuk memahami beberapa aspek maklumat kuantum dan ia juga kebetulannya agak cantik dari sudut pandang
matematik jadi saya harap korang akan sertai saya untuk unit tiga dan selamat tinggal sehingga
itu